[Music]
in it be like that yes if you like they
feel like you like that if you like that
sometimes that's like that maybe like
that true submitted by give me the loot
it's a biggie song yeah
biggie smile shameful - I mean but you
listen to like cure and like all that
stuff it's older to be small and
somethin on he's like from the 70s so
SME muchos [ __ ] I know even Lionel
Hansen he's from the 40s damn girl you
swing is Lionel him you should come up I
love his music what kind of music is it
it's like jazz it's not big bad but like
jazzy what do you mean by jazzy stuff
Quincy Jones was on his band because of
Quincy's played trumpet for him so then
what's your excuse for biggie [ __ ] your
excuse should be West Coast for life
that's exactly just be like posh now say
a Tupac saw what was for iron hey Human
Resources worker who was evicted from
her home was denied rental assistance
for her own 8th gen C why because she
make too much money
yeah oh I thought it's good she got
evicted because she made too much money
to get assistance oh that [ __ ] it's like
it's like a person that helps other
people get housing because they're lower
income or whatever she actually becomes
lower income and loses her job but she
can't get housing she didn't lose her
job she wasn't able to get assistance um
through the hurt the job that she worked
that yeah so it's the ironic but not
fool the ironic she just makes too much
exactly so is it you could be a social
worker and make six figures and even
though you help people you're not gonna
get the wealth for the future so she
didn't even qualify for this distance
then yeah because of her pain right but
um so she what so Yvette she's 51 years
old I almost became a social worker I'm
glad I did it
I'm glad you
- man it's rough I thought you're
telling me I'm glad your date either cuz
you'd be [ __ ] lives up that - what
well no it's cuz I care about you for my
friend and my sisters one and I know how
rough it is first ten hard as an
emotionally hard or [ __ ] with people
oh oh oh my god cuz I would have just
laughed that well that I'm working with
like no that's what happened your life
saw Tommy well I'm gonna try to help you
get some money right now but tell me
more man that's just can I get a new
social worker please he's helping me but
did you laughing no he was like dad it
beats me war [ __ ] my dad used to do that
[ __ ] - Gilles [ __ ] those [ __ ]
up and then he starts a gang and their
social working gang did anybody comes
the bubble King he's almost there dude
we always see in this room the only
thing that separates Joe and a bum is
just the amount of money that he has
nice my lucky dice that's gonna be
that's how people are gonna know you
coming funky you roll that dice exactly
like you rose it down the alley every
was like alright so back to you that
here is 51 she's worked for the city's
human resources and administration for
the past 15 years
haha she has recently been falling
through hard times because she's been
helping her brother support his family
because he's been ill right she got
tired most of her money or like she's
not most of it but a lot of her money is
going to helping out her brothers that's
nice and so she's been showing that like
she's showed the agency that information
and also her mom passed away so there
was a lot of expensive
there's life circumstances here yeah and
so now she was getting evicted and she
applied for a $2,000 rental assistance
so she wouldn't get evicted from that's
it all she was asking for was $2,000 or
is it a monthly - cheese
I think it's monthly maybe month okay
I'm not sure I just it didn't tell me it
was monthly or not but um but she does
she was rejected because she makes
seventy seven thousand a year I would
feel like she would have some sort of
like employee perk from from the company
that's why I mean that's kind of weird
because even when you sign up for
financial aid like they take into
consideration if you have children if
you're married how many dependents you
have right you're taking care of right
yeah cuz your brother and his family
should be yeah you you could be making a
hundred thousand dollars but if you're
[ __ ] spending a hundred and one you're
broke
yeah if you have ten kids all right [ __ ]
that company I like her I know she looks
like she needs a good suit wholesome
woman you know she looks like your
everyday third-grade teacher right yeah
so I bet you she rescued a lot of people
and were they now still broke okay
imagine imagine you're on welfare right
social worker comes helps you get get
out of welfare hopefully you become
middle-class class is kind of what about
the people that [ __ ] help you you're
gonna give money to them gotta give back
that's all I'm saying
every [ __ ] shoe I found was a social
worker see this is why I would be a
horrible social worker I will go back to
every single person I helped out I made
you a [ __ ] millionaire you owe me you
owe me I want I want a percentage of
your income wow that's that's not doing
social work distortion I know
that's not social workmen okay let's say
all right let's say you want to come to
America all right so I bring you in this
country a good job in this country I
give you education I sponsor you all
that stuff the least you could do is pay
me back on my investment that I spent
bringing you into America getting you a
job here right and then on top of that
for the rest of your life give me two
percent that's all I asked for two
percent this is different because this
is her job and she got paid for all that
she's no directly working with people
either cuz she works as a computer
specialist in the HR department so she'd
be hiring or HR a okay okay but anyway
so then she ended up having to leave her
place because they didn't give her any
assistance so she had to move in with
her brother who has like his wife and
kid and twelve cats she has a boyfriend
and a kid and so like they had to move
in there and why does she move him with
the boyfriend
yeah wait what's the boyfriend doing
he's a loser oh maybe maybe that's why I
didn't qualify cuz the household income
if she makes 77 by herself and then plus
the boyfriend that's already there might
be too much money to qualify yeah so she
has a son and then the brother has the
wife a son and a granddaughter just a
lot of family members yeah you bet has
two dogs as well so she moved into his
cramped a roach infested apartment this
takes place in New York families the
dogs could eat all roaches
and then it's partially uninhabitable
due to flooding there's a lot of people
he could kick all the water together the
landlord doesn't get any repairs so she
is trying to find or trying to get
assistance from the Department of
homeless services and they're
considering the option of going into a
homeless shelter Wow Wow that's like
such a drastic change of life
circumstances when she went to go get
help
we're like ask for help they told her
like well so much good go move out of
state she was like the [ __ ] was here my
life is here that's it might sound shady
but that's exactly where my mind went I
was like you know so we're cheaper yeah
New York is [ __ ] expensive I go to
Jersey girl if you live in like
Virginia or wherever you know you could
have a decent home and house everybody I
mean they're also the boonie areas of
New York too
you know it's not like oh they're not in
New York New York I don't know
well are they in like a Bushwick it's
like more of like upstate or something
yeah yeah it's just crazy that she makes
70 G's a year almost 80 actually she's
like an $80,000 a year homeless person
yeah exactly that's like this mind well
it makes sense cuz of how many people
she's taking care of well so there's
there's her brother yeah that's sick she
might even be paying for medical bills
or whatever it'll be I mean how many
kids does he have three kids
one child one child two actually who
knows if her boyfriend is working or not
either she might be taking care of him
too
he's either a loser or he's got his own
set of problems where he's taking care
of his own family too you know like like
hard times man yeah I mean she just had
to pay for a big funeral that's that's
[ __ ] money yeah yeah that's like
paying for a wedding you know just it's
like 20 ki thing out the window yeah
that's crazy man yeah and not to mention
all the other bills she probably has
student loans all that [ __ ] it sounds
like she didn't hurt life circumstances
prevented her from having a savings
account because they were just money
probably coming it was going out every I
think that's most people they say most
people yeah they're average them how
much they have in their bank account
it's about 200 bucks that's most people
that's [ __ ] scary it is no I think I
think three out of five Americans don't
even have a savings account I just
yeah I think most of what well she
probably had a savings account it's just
that was also in her expense account she
just took the money out okay yeah I'm
sure she had the money it just wasn't an
actual separate account I did have a say
because just I didn't put a lot of money
ins you know how much is in my savings
[Laughter]
well technically you do have a save as
the count he does we call this right
here not even that to because we had the
same tax guy he makes us put it into our
[ __ ] Roth IRA yeah
you do that because the savings savings
is actually just started work you don't
want to leave money in your savings
account because you you lose money every
year to interest yeah we don't lose
money you're just not making money the
value of your money is last I I feel
like stories like this is something that
kind of gets picked up I read it and
they start like a GoFundMe for for these
type of people I hope so yeah hopefully
somebody you know reaches out to [ __ ]
life sometimes kicks you in the [ __ ]
acid I know like dude be [ __ ] nice to
a sometime you know what the hard part
is too is no one's really taught
financial education that's what I'm
sayin
schools need a [ __ ] teach this [ __ ]
like how to do taxes who the [ __ ] needs
to learn calculus and trigonometry is
that everyone says like everyone said
that teach kids life skills I don't even
know [ __ ] algebra dude did you forget
I forgot everything dude I don't know
what's the [ __ ] the first/last inside
out what's it boil method yeah well
that's not that's though that's for
white people oh I should slow dude if I
teach your kids math it's gonna be way
fast
no I don't want my kids to be smarter
than daddy though guys stop the minute
yeah you do you want them to support you
that's right be smarter than daddy and
you could be smart just act like you're
dumb and then I don't know what to do
that's my dad all the time dude I found
out my dad's [ __ ] English is perfect
when my grandpa died dude it's all that
I don't know how to do this you can you
call 18 people or me perfectly unique as
Ferrando and it to me the transfer to
the other one my grandpa passed away the
funeral thing it is like oh thank you
for giving you your condolences
condolences a big English war mister no
English
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]